first of all hey how's school going
how's the first week of classes oh it's
good man I gotta hurt yourself I got
homework I got to do huh yeah I want to
know you try to get the full college
experience we can see you got some frat
parties or what I don't know about yeah
you are okay I'm gonna try to limit the
extracurricular activities I got
companies and stuff I got a run but I'm
definitely gonna partake all right let's
talk about this show there was a lot of
shade being thrown today how'd it feel
being served by one of the youngest
contestants on the show I just outgrew
Barbies like Mariah did Nick
she was wiling out it was all in fun man
she's outstanding she's hilarious you
have to give Mariah heads-up when stuff
like that goes down John you do man and
she thinks like I'm the one that put
people up to that stuff I give myself in
enough trouble so I was like I I think
you know but she she has fun with it too
she knows that you know there's no hard
feelings and it's all love some people
joking I make jokes it's all in jest
you